VINAY SHET: The reason
we are here today
is because spam continues
to be a major problem
on the internet.
ReCAPTCHA's mission
is to fight the spam
and to keep the internet clean.
We believe a spam-free,
clean internet is
a better internet for everyone.
My name is Vinay Shet.
I'm a product manager
for reCAPTCHA.
I'm here today with my
colleagues Aaron [INAUDIBLE]
and Aaron [INAUDIBLE]
who are engineering
leads for reCAPTCHA.
And we have an exciting
session planned for you today.
They are going to start
by giving a sense of,
an overview of what
reCAPTCHA is and how
it has evolved in the last few
years to get to where it is
has gotten to today.
We'll then go under the hood
and see how reCAPTCHA works
and how you can reCAPTCHA
on your site or your apps
to fight spam.
We'll then take a quick look at
some recently released features
and some upcoming features
that they're launching soon.
And then we have some
very exciting talks
on a couple of our partners.
We have [? Dan ?] [INAUDIBLE]
from Ticketmaster joining us
today to tell us how to get
master users reCAPTCHA's
to fight bots.
And we have [? Danny ?]
[? Grant ?] from Cloudflare
joining us today as well to
tell us how they used reCAPTCHA
to make a better
experience for their users.
And towards the end, we're
going to show you something
that I think you're going
to find extremely exciting.
All right, so today
a significant amount
of the traffic on the internet
comes from automated bots.
These bots hurt your
site and your apps.
They could do so by
creating fake accounts,
by posting
inappropriate comments,
or by engaging in fraud or
abuse on an e-commerce system,
or by simply posting
spamming emails or messages.
In other words, if
your site or app
has any resource of any
value, it is prone to abuse
by these bots.
But reCAPTCHA can help.
ReCAPTCHA is a free
API that you can
use on your site or your app
to fight the span and abuse,
and you can do so while
letting your valid users
through with these.
If you use reCAPTCHA
on your site today,
this is what it would look like.
You would embed a widget
which is a checkbox that says,
I'm not a robot.
When users come
to this checkbox,
they would click on that
or tap on the checkbox
to show that they are human.
And for a significant fraction
of your users, that is all
they would have to do.
The checkbox would check,
and they would get through
to the next page.
Now for a certain
fraction of your users,
you would prompt a challenge.
You would say, hey,
prove you are really
a human by, in this example,
clicking on all the pictures
that to show a coffee.
So a single click or a few
taps or some other times.
ReCAPTCHA today is utilized
by over a million customers,
by companies or
organizations worldwide.
Every day we just
see on the order
of hundreds of
millions of solutions
back from across 240
locales around the world.
So we have a fairly broad
view of the abusive activity
that happens around the world.
So the bad guys cannot hide.
Oh, and reCAPTCHA is
also available to you
in over 56 languages.
So no matter where in
the world your users are,
reCAPTCHA has a solution for
them and will work for them.
But this is easy, right?
A single checkbox, a few
taps, and you're through.
But reCAPTCHA was
not always this easy.
As recently as two years ago,
this is what reCAPTCHA was,
right?
This is what we call
syntactic, distorted text.
Let me say it again.
It's a mouthful.
Syntactic distorted text.
Synthetic because we
would generate the image.
We would take text of words,
and we know what the word is,
and you'd create
it into an image,
and then the human would
say, hey, what word is it?
And they would type it out.
And 10 years ago, literally, if
you said that the idea was that
a human could read that,
but machines could not
because computer vision
or artificial intelligence
was not yet at the point
where they could do that.
But guess what?
It began catching up.
It began catching
up to a point where
we had to distorting the text
because the more you distort,
the harder it is for machines.
Oh, yeah, it's hard
for humans too,
but yeah, sure, they
read the thing somehow.
If they squint a little bit
hard they could read it.
Right?
But ultimately it
got so bad, the image
on the right hand side there?
That's crazy image is one of the
hardest in our text distorted
[INAUDIBLE].
And two years ago in 2014 we
asked ourselves a question.
All right, so synthetic
distorted text
is what's the rage right now.
Can it really tell humans
and machines apart?
So we took the hardest
variant of this reCAPTCHA
that we had, and we
showed it to some humans.
They were able to get
through at 33% accuracy.
That's a third.
All right?
All right, right, so
humans can pass at 33%.
What about machines?
So we gave the same CAPTCHA's
to our state-of-the-art machine
learning algorithm that our own
team had built within Google.
And this was two
years ago by the way.
This was 2014.
And the results shocked us.
So the state of the art machine
learning algorithm in 2014
was able to solve the hardest
synthetic distorted text
CAPTCHAs at 99.8% precision.
[LAUGHTER]
Now when most of you
folks think of CAPTCHAs,
these are the kind of CAPTCHAs
you're thinking about,
this synthetic distorted text.
This was a wake up call.
We had to go back
to our drawing board
literally to say, What
can we do to change this,
to pivot into
something that actually
works in the real world.
And that's when we decided
to go into [INAUDIBLE]
and learn something called
a risk analysis engine.
A risk analysis engine is a
back end that does not look only
at the solution
to that challenge,
but rather looks at the
whole engagement the user has
with that CAPTCHA
holistically, and then uses
that try to determine whether
someone is a human or a bot.
In doing so, the challenge
is useful, but not
the only component.
The second elementary really
was that we moved away
from a synthetic image,
one that was generated
by us, into a natural image.
We could now tap
into street view
to try to see how we
can use a natural image
and use that as a
challenge when required.
In 2016, the state of the
art in computer vision
is still not at a point
where at scale you
can understand everything
in the natural image,
so it does provide some
degree of signal there.
Now, of course, this
will not be true forever.
We have a window of time
as the eye catches up,
as computer vision catches up.
But as of today it works.
And what our team
is going to focus on
is to try to stay
ahead of the curve.
As technology evolves,
we keep trying
to improve our system,
[INAUDIBLE] technology
it was, to stay
ahead of the curve
and to provide the best
security [INAUDIBLE].
But now let's tell
you a little bit more
about what's behind this risk
analysis engine, and to do so,
I call upon Ying Liu.
YING LIU: Thanks, Vinay.
My name is Ying.
I'm a 10-year-old
Google engineer.
So that's the same
age with Google IL.
I just look a little
bit older than that.
So let me take you
behind the scenes,
and let's all check out how
reCAPTCHA actually works.
Turns out you just
need two lines of code.
The first line is to request
a JavaScript library from us,
and the second line
is the div to render
the I'm not a robot widget.
So as a developer, you
embed these two lines
of code in your web page
and [INAUDIBLE] a request
to the reCAPTCHA server.
And in response we give you
the widget itself together
with some JavaScript library.
And when your end user clicks on
the I'm not a robot check mark,
it sends another
HTTP request to us.
And this time, we're looking
at the wide range of signals
that you're sending to us
including the full HTTP stack,
IP address, and et cetera.
And on the server side, there's
something really interesting
is happening.
So as Vinay was
mentioning, we're
deploying advanced
risk analysis system,
which is using machine
learning to predict
how abusive this
incoming request is.
And based on this
prediction, we give you
different CAPTCHA treatment.
So if a well-behaved
human, we give you
a green check directly.
For bad bots we reject
you right on the spot.
That's a Photoshop
of the rejection.
The actual picture
doesn't look like that.
It was much worse.
But everything else in
between, when we're not sure,
when we think you're suspicious
we give you different CAPTCHAs.
Here I'm just showing
you two examples.
The one on the left is
a three-by-three grid.
We're showing you
nine natural images,
and you're asked to select
the common object among them.
The one on the right
is even harder.
Here we have one natural
image, and you're
asked to select to locate
a particular object
inside that picture.
So as of today,
2016, this is still
considered very difficult.
Even for advanced AI.
Now with this
preclassification, it
allows us to do a lot of
interesting experiments,
and we start to gaining
insight about how
humans and bots behave
differently on the internet.
And for the next few
slides, I'm going
to share with you
some of the insights.
So as I mentioned just now,
there's preclassification,
and for highly
suspicious traffic,
we give them very
difficult CAPTCHAs.
And this is how bots
behave-- they walk away.
So here I'm showing two bars.
The blue one is the
number of challenges.
So challenge is defined as a
click on the checkbox of I'm
not a robot, and the red bar is
the number of solutions, that's
attempts to solve a CAPTCHA
when we are presented with one.
So as you can see
here is a big drop
from challenges to solutions.
So it turns out
for bots, only 5%
of the challenges
lead into a solution,
and the remaining 95%,
they abandoned the CAPTCHA
experience.
So you might wonder how
does that work for humans
if you present them a
very hard CAPTCHA, right?
So we did this experiment
on humans where we give them
the same hard CAPTCHAs, and
it turns out more than 90%
of humans actually try
to solve this CAPTCHA.
So there's a huge difference
in terms of behavior
between bots and humans.
So reCAPTCHA's mission has been
helping the internet clean,
keep it free of spam and abuse.
So to do that, we cannot
drive humans away.
Actually, the humans' usability
is a top priority for us,
so with the preclassification,
we can give humans
a lot easier challenges.
So in the one that means
much easier text distortions,
and the v-1 human users
get an 89% pass rate.
So here pass rate is defined
as the passed solutions
over total number of solutions.
When we get onto V2, that number
is significant proving to 96%.
And for the remaining
4% of human users,
you failed, but you
can always try again.
And CAPTCHA solving has
been faster and faster
for human beings.
So in V1, because
it's text distortion
that you have to type in
through your keyboards,
which is particularly
hard for mobile users.
In V2, that experience has
changed into mouse clicks
or even screen touches.
So with that, we have
seen the solving time
for humans has reduced
by half, and that
means having humans solving
online was saving them
few seconds, and cumulatively
that is 50,000 hours every day
that we save internet users.
50,000 hours every day that
is six man years, and that
is a lot of cats
and dogs videos you
could have watched on YouTube
rather than solving CAPTCHAs.
And I think YouTube
should thank us for this.
So every day we receive
hundreds of millions
of CAPTCHA solutions, and
among the past solutions,
roughly one third
of them is coming
from no CAPTCHA experience.
So of course that number
varies side by side.
So to find out the particular
number for your sites,
Aaron is going to explain
more details, how to get that.
So this is a map of the overall
pass rate we observed from V1.
So here is color coded
by red as being low
pass rate, meaning most
of the solutions failed.
And green is high pass rate.
Most of them succeeded.
When we move on to
V2, you see it's
transitioning into a
land of green which
means whenever you envounter
V2 reCAPTCHA on the internet,
you're most likely to solve it
correctly, but if you're bots,
you're most likely to walk away.
So to recap reCAPTCHA, it
is getting easier and faster
for humans and harder for bots.
What that means for
you as a developer is
that your human users will enjoy
a much higher conversion rate,
and the bots are blocked out.
So next, I'll have
Dan from Ticketmaster
to share us a story of
how reCAPTCHA V2 has
helped Ticketmaster human users
to buy more tickets online.
So with that, Dan.
DAN: Thanks, Ying.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN: Hi, everyone.
So my name's Dan
[INAUDIBLE], and I'm
the director of abuse prevention
for Ticketmaster and Live
Nation, and what
that means to you
guys is that myself
and my team, we battle
again bots all the time
trying to get you tickets
and keep people who aren't
people out of events.
The long and short of it is
that this is our entire jobs,
just like it is for them.
We stop bots.
Ticketmaster is a
40-year-old company.
We're just celebrating our
40th anniversary this year,
and 2015 about 12,000
clients, 43,000 events,
465 million tickets, and
38 billion web requests
we serviced.
Bots are an absolutely
massive problem for us,
just like they are for you guys.
We want to get you guys in.
When I go to bed I dream
about bots, so I'm not weird.
And when I wake up, I
dream about bots still.
That that might make me weird.
But the, oh no, sorry
no tickets found.
Yeah, you don't
like to see that.
We don't like you
see that either.
This can be, if it's a week
after an event goes on sale,
it's OK.
You know, it's in a
normal organic traffic.
If it's an hour after,
it kind of sucks,
but it's still maybe OK.
If it's 15 seconds
in, I'm sure you
have some pretty
choice words about
that particular situation.
So we don't want that
to happen, and this
is sometimes due to bots,
sometimes other things.
But a lot of bots.
So what do the bots
and bad actors do?
Why do we have the problems
in general with people
not able to get tickets?
Like we said, bots again.
The thing is CAPTCHA farms.
So they'll take these CAPTCHAs,
they'll ship them off to China,
get them solved for low rates,
they'll ship back the solution,
then they can continue going
through with their programs.
They violate ticket limits.
So we say eight tickets
allowed, they'll buy 800, 8,000?
There's some number they can
actually accomplish in getting.
They'll use other system
exploits to get tickets,
and then finally they'll
hold inventory in reserve.
They'll put it on
a secondary market.
If they sell it, they buy it.
If they don't sell it, they
release it back into inventory.
And we call this
no-risk arbitrage.
And we need that to stop too.
This market for just this
is $4-5 billion a year.
So the bad guys who are
trying to get these tickets,
they have a lot of
money at stake here.
So Ticketmaster, we use a
lot of different strategies.
This is a few of them.
We use a lot-- like you guys--
like the IT blocking schemes
based on velocities, we'll
look at the IP addresses,
we'll look at the sider blocks
that are coming through,
the accounts that
people are using,
the device identifiers
as well, and there's
a bunch of other things
that we use as well.
We have internal
machine learning,
and so we have a team
of data scientists
that's dedicated to
determining and figuring out
what the bot signatures are
and how things are actually
behaving to predict
who's good and who's bad.
So they'll say, You guys
look good, you guys look bad.
I'm not used to holding
two things here, sorry.
So, and so it'll categorize
based on how you appear to be.
So these people looked good.
You look good coming through,
we'll put you with that group.
You guys look bad, we're going
to put you with that group.
So that's how we
internally we'll
do that by categorization.
And we have a little bit of
experience with CAPTCHA, too.
So our history with
CAPTCHA, actually, we
wrote our own a
bunch of years back,
and it was fairly effective
for a little while.
And then we also
had another CAPTCHA
as well that was still
based on the text,
and as [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned, the OCRs
have gotten really good,
fabulously good, better
than pretty much any people are.
So when you have that
type of CAPTCHA presented,
the ability for bots
to get through it
is actually better than
the ability for humans
to get through it.
So this is the presentation we
have on Ticketmaster right now,
the check box that
you like to see.
And for me, I love this because,
when I get up for an on sale,
I buy tickets too.
We're all fans.
We go to a lot of events.
And when I see this in the
morning I'm like, whew,
I don't need glasses
and a shot of tequila
to get through this experience,
so it makes me really happy.
And so what it's meant that
Ticketmaster, really, is we're
confident we're getting
more fans through.
And we have a lot
of spiky traffic.
We have a lot of big
on sales that we do,
so some of these spikes could
be Garth Brooks and Beyonce
and Adele and that
type of stuff,
and then when those on sales
complete, traffic kind of drops
back off.
But the averages before
reCAPTCHA enablement
were higher than they are now.
So for a lot of you guys,
a reduction in traffic
may or may not be good,
for us is very good.
We're getting 70% less traffic
in the same number sales.
So 270% increase in
conversion rate, so fabulous.
Thank you.
And then post-conversion,
post-CAPTCHA conversion rate
as well is another
gate that we check.
And so it's like, when
somebody goes through CAPTCHA,
do they actually buy something?
And so the conversion rate
when we had the AB testing was,
we set it at 1.
The new conversion rate
is 226% greater than that.
So we know that more
fans are getting
tickets out of that experience.
So again, to quote
Ying, to recap
RECAPTCHA for Ticketmaster,
it's been better for us.
70% less traffic going to the
event pages, so that's good.
Event page conversion rate
has really been great,
the post-CAPTCHA conversion
rate up by 230%, and then
the carted conversion rate, or
when somebody puts something
in their cart, do they buy it?
Up by 128%, so
that's been awesome.
Things are really much
harder to measure,
but we kind of get an indication
based on like Twitter feeds
and what people are writing
about their experience
and seeing things, less
bots getting tickets.
So he's not super
happy about that.
You have a lot better
ease in getting tickets,
because the inventory will be
there for you to access it.
Actually, the
ecosystem comes down
so the ticket prices
for your average entry
will end up being
lower, because you
don't have to go to secondary
markets to buy them.
And then we have our
little rock one guy,
you get the rock
one more because you
have to spend less money.
Thank you.
And with that, I'm going
to pass on to Aaron.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
I'm Aaron Malenfant.
I'm with the reCAPTCHA team.
So you saw Ying present stats
on how reCAPTCHA does globally.
And you saw Dan present
some stats on how reCAPTCHA
works for Ticketmaster.
But you're probably
wondering, how
does reCAPTCHA work
for you and your site?
You may not know
this, but reCAPTCHA
has a number of charts and
graphs on our admin console
which are specific to your site.
To get there, you can
go to g.co/recaptcha.
Click Get ReCAPTCHA.
And from there, you'll
see a list of sites
that you've registered with us.
If you don't have
a site yet, you
can also register one there.
So once you're there, you
can click on your site.
And the first chart,
which we launched
when we launch reCAPTCHA,
was a pass/fail chart.
So this is, for all
the CAPTCHAs we served,
was it passed or failed?
But as you saw from Ying's
presentation, with V2,
the bots don't even
try to solve it.
So it wasn't really giving
us a good metric of how
effective reCAPTCHA is doing.
So earlier this week,
we launched a new chart
which is a session pass rate.
What this says is, for
all the traffic which
clicked on the I'm
not a robot check box,
did they eventually pass?
Or did they walk away?
And so this will give you an
idea of your own conversion
rate for reCAPTCHA.
We also have a chart which
gives the average session time.
And again, this is from the
time the user clicks on the,
I'm not a robot, to
whether they succeed.
This tells you how
much time your users
are spending to solve CAPTCHAs.
Another thing we've
been dealing with lately
is that not all websites have
the same value to spammers.
And also, not every
place on your website
has the same value.
There are some places where
the bots and the bad actors
will spend real money to try
to break in, because they can
make some money out of that.
And we treat-- we
previously treated
those two things the same way.
So recently we
added a way for you
to signal to us how you
want to treat the traffic.
Should we optimize for security?
Or should we optimize
for usability?
And this is-- in the case where
we know it's a human or a bot,
we still treat it the same.
But this allows you to signal
to us which way you wish us just
to bias our
decisions so that you
can make the appropriate
decision for your site
or for different
places on your site.
To enable this feature,
you go to the same place
that you would for
the charts and graphs.
And at the bottom, you can
open up the Advanced Settings
and set the Security
Preference for your site.
By default though, we recommend
you just leave it in the middle
and let us make the decision.
But for areas where you want
to bias towards usability--
for instance, let's say you
had a contact your sales form.
And if there was some
spam that got in there,
that's not that big of a deal.
We're still protecting
you against bad actors,
but we're [? biased ?] a little
more towards the usable side
so that as much of-- so your
users have the easiest time.
But let's say you're in
a place where spammers
are willing to put
real money behind it,
then we want you to
go to Most Usable.
So for commerce, maybe
Forgot My Password
links, those type
of things where you
want to bias towards security.
So now, Dani from
CloudFlare is going
to talk about how they used this
to solve a problem that they
were having.
DANI GRANT: Hey, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm Dani, and I'm the Product
Manager working closely
with Google's reCAPTCHA
at CloudFlare.
CloudFlare is a content
delivery network
that also makes websites
resilient to attacks.
Content delivery networks
sit in between the visitor
and the origin web server,
and accelerate traffic
in between them.
What makes CloudFlare unique
is its special attention
to security.
When CloudFlare
proxies web traffic,
it let's good traffic in,
but keeps bad traffic out.
Four million websites
use CloudFlare.
So every second, we serve
3 and 1/2 million webpages.
CloudFlare uses
Google's reCAPTCHA
to verify visitors when
we've seen their IP addresses
previously in cyber attacks.
We're pretty big fans
of Google's reCAPTCHA.
That's a picture of
our office in London
where Google helps us
keep our beer safe.
We see a lot of cyber attacks.
This is a snapshot of just
some of our DDoS attack traffic
volume.
So we end up serving
a lot of CAPTCHAs.
We serve a billion and a
half CAPTCHA pages every day.
I want to talk to you about
one interesting challenge
of serving reCAPTCHA, which is
serving to the users of the Tor
browser.
Tor makes a browser
that allows anyone
to surf the web anonymously.
Anonymity is incredibly
important for people
who have their speech or access
to the internet restricted
all over the world.
Unfortunately, anonymity
is also really useful
if you're a cyber criminal.
And so unfortunately,
94% of the traffic
we see from the Tor browser
is malicious traffic.
That means that when
Tor visitors visit
CloudFlare websites, their
IP reputation scores often
trigger CAPTCHAs.
Google takes the following
logic, the more abusive
the traffic, the
more challenging
the CAPTCHA should be.
There are a few ways to
make a challenging CAPTCHA.
One is to serve images
that are visually
similar or instructions
that our lingually nuanced.
This guards against
bots that are
using computer vision to
solve the CAPTCHAs themselves.
But not all bots are doing this.
Some are randomly
guessing at the CAPTCHAs.
And for them, the
guard is to require
multiple correct
solutions of the CAPTCHA
to complete the
CAPTCHA challenge.
The more correct solutions
you require, the less likely
a bot is to randomly guess
the CAPTCHA challenge.
And so, for the
most suspicious IPs,
Google would serve
difficult CAPTCHAs
that would require
multiple correct solutions.
This could be a very frustrating
experience for a Tor user.
We care a lot about the
usability of the internet.
And so we were trying
to find a solution.
And then Google did
something very neat.
They offered this toggle
that, among other things,
would allow us to cap
the number of CAPTCHAs
in each CAPTCHA
challenge at one.
We care a lot about the
usability of the internet,
more than allowing
a few extra bots in.
And so, when they
released this setting,
we turned the slider
to the left right away.
And now, if you
encounter a CAPTCHA
through CloudFlare,
even through Tor,
you only get one
CAPTCHA per challenge.
I can show you what this
looks like on the Edge.
So this chart shows the two
weeks before and two weeks
after we made this change.
And this yellow
line is the day we
turned the slider to the left.
The dark blue line at the
top is the total amount
of CAPTCHA sessions we serve.
And the light blue
line at the bottom
is the total number of sessions
that were successfully passed.
You can see that after
we made this change,
there's no increase in the
number of sessions passed.
This means that, even
though the CAPTCHA is now
easier for users, no
extra bots are getting in.
This is cool.
Here's something interesting.
This chart shows the
total number of CAPTCHAs
that we serve, including
the duplicate CAPTCHAs
inside the you
need to solve more
to complete the CAPTCHA
challenge CAPTCHA loops.
Right away, when we turned
the slider to the left,
the number of CAPTCHAs that
we have served dropped by 70%.
This is a win.
This means that we are able
to serve 70% less CAPTCHAs,
but still not let
in any more bots.
And because users have
to solve less CAPTCHAs,
they're faster getting
in through the site.
Immediately when we
turned on this option,
users took 17% less time to get
through the CAPTCHA challenge.
This is cool.
So we're really happy
with the solution.
And we hope tor users are, too.
I'm going to hand this
back to Vinay and Aaron.
[APPLAUSE]
VINAY SHET: Thank you, Dani.
That was an awesome story.
Thanks for sharing
that with this.
So I hope by now you've seen
that reCAPTCHA has truly
evolved over the
last several years.
We have moved from a
synthetic distorted text
into a risk analysis
engine that looks
at the traffic in
a holistic manner.
And in doing so, it has
truly become more secure
and is more effective
at stopping bots.
You heard from
Ticketmaster how, when
they began using reCAPTCHA, they
were able to stop more bots,
and their user conversion
actually went up.
You heard from CloudFlare how
when they began the switching
on to this new
version, they were
able to let the valued
users pass through easily,
while not seeing any increase
in the abusive activity.
So the key point here really
is that, as technology evolves,
as we see in more and
emerging threats coming up,
we will stay abreast
with those threats.
And hopefully we'll
stay ahead of the curve
so that you don't have to
worry about the security--
or spam abusing your site.
And by doing all of this
stuff, we are relentlessly
focusing on usability.
How can we make this as easy
as possible for the user?
So today already, a significant
number of users on your site
can get through
with just one click.
But, but can we do better?
Are we done with just this?
Let's ask Aaron.
Hey, Aaron.
Come on up.
How you doing?
AARON MALENFANT: Good.
No, we--
DANI GRANT: Are we done?
AARON MALENFANT:
We're not done yet.
What if we could make it zero
clicks instead of one click?
VINAY SHET: Zero clicks.
What do you mean?
AARON MALENFANT: Let me show
you a screencast of something
we're working on right now.
VINAY SHET: Sorry.
AARON MALENFANT: Let's say
that the next generation
smartphone is coming
out, and they're
going for a retro style.
VINAY SHET: I would buy that.
AARON MALENFANT: And you
know that a lot of people
are going to attempt
to buy this and sell it
on the secondary
market, so you want
to put a CAPTCHA on the page.
So the user would
come to the form.
They would enter
their information out,
type in their email
address, pick a color,
and then click Buy Now.
And that's it.
VINAY SHET: That's it?
Wait, what just happened there?
Go back.
Take it back.
So this is a normal form.
The user just enters
their normal information,
and you would have had a
CAPTCHA on this page, correct?
AARON MALENFANT: That's correct.
VINAY SHET: But in
this particular case,
they fill out the
information, they hit Buy Now,
and that's it?
AARON MALENFANT: Yes.
VINAY SHET: Wait.
Was there a CAPTCHA on the page?
AARON MALENFANT: Yes.
It was invisible.
VINAY SHET: The
invisible CAPTCHA.
How does it work?
AARON MALENFANT: So we'll
do the risk analysis
before you click
the Buy Now button,
so that way we know,
when you click Buy Now,
if we're going to give
you a no CAPTCHA or not.
That way the third of the users
that would get the no CAPTCHA
don't have to click
on anything at all.
VINAY SHET: That's amazing.
So the fractions
of users who today
get a no CAPTCHA single click,
would, in this experience,
see nothing at all?
AARON MALENFANT: That's correct.
VINAY SHET: That's awesome.
Has this launched
already, Aaron?
AARON MALENFANT: Not yet.
We will provide a link
at the end for beta sign
ups for anyone interested.
VINAY SHET: That is cool.
We have a video, don't we?
AARON MALENFANT: Yes.
VINAY SHET: Shall we roll video?
AARON MALENFANT: Sure.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Since the launch of the
no CAPTCHA reCAPTCHA,
a simple check box has
helped identify humans
from even this sneakiest bots,
stopping billions of attacks
on websites around the world.
But to stay one step
ahead of the bad guys,
reCAPTCHA needed
to keep evolving
to ensure the most
delightful user experience.
And now we're taking
it even further.
Can you see it?
Of course not.
It's invisible.
Powering these advances
is a combination
of machine learning
and advanced risk
analysis that adapt to
new and emerging threats.
So whether on desktop or
mobile, reCAPTCHA still
means no frustration.
People get to where
they're going faster.
And everyone stays
happy, except bots.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
VINAY SHET: Thank you, everyone,
for coming to this talk.
The link on the top is where you
would sign up for learning more
about invisible CAPTCHA.
There's some slap-up
stickers down here.
So please pick them
up on your way out.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]